I would start by doing some real due
diligence I would get to know the
organization what we found on both the
boards that I've served on but also our
organization that I lead is that if
people show up with passion and really
understanding the organization before
they become a board member they're far
more successful and those board members
who show up because a company told them
they should be on the board or because
they have a lot of money but they don't
have a passion for what we're doing
haven't lasted very long you're also
looking for a good fit with the core
team on that nonprofit so is the
executive director someone with whom you
get energy you enjoy seeing you trust
them you a good relationship and rapport
and then who's the board chair or who
serves on that board who will you be
spending the majority of your time with
and learning from that experience
building a relationship for these people
that you're going to enjoy seeing are
they people that you can relate to
they're people that would bring
different experiences to you that you
will learn and develop and then when
you're also looking you want to look at
the organization how long has it been in
history you know what is its financial
history look like are there any long
term commitments that they've made that
would concern you or that might there
might be some opportunities ahead of the
organization that excite you and
hopefully after you've done your
homework checking on the stature of the
organization looking at some of their
competitors as well you can come back to
that board chair or the executive
director and say these are the questions
that I have and have another
conversation about how you create value
for that organization and then how you
will be part of a team that ultimately
helps that organization a tree achieve
impact
volunteer a little bit work with them on
a task force see how they are see if
these are individuals that you'd like to
team up with see if this potentially is
a board that you'd be interested in
joining show that you have an interest
but also have them show you how they
might interact with you worst thing in
the world is going on a board cold and
then finding out it's not what I thought
it was or they're not really using me
for anything other than some money in my
network and so testing them out a little
bit and having a dating period it's
probably a good idea and what you do
you'll you'll find some things that you
are able to play with them in a unified
fashion to have an impact on those
things you're passionate about when it
comes to selecting a board you really
need to look at what the role of that
board member is in the nonprofit couple
ways to look at that first of all what
about size so most small nonprofits are
under two million dollars in revenue per
year I mean there are millions of
nonprofits in this country and so many
are being created every day but you want
to be sure that if that organization is
under two million then you will have a
much more hands-on role as a board
member than if it is between two and
five million less involvement and then
huge boards like the Stanford the
Stanford Board of Trustees has even less
oversight in terms of day-to-day
operations of the nonprofit so if you
really want to get involved in strategy
as I would encourage the students to do
then finding smaller boards will have
much much more meaningful opportunities
for hands-on engagement so I would look
at the size of the organization in terms
of its revenue and then also in terms of
the number of employees
what are the attitude what's the
knowledge that I bring to a non-profit
board and what are they looking for it
is it aligned with the expectations
every board I've ever worked with is
different I have a colleague that says
when you've seen one board you've seen
one board and so every board is going to
expect different things with respect to
fundraising expectations or attendance
at meetings time of day of meeting so
you really have to align yourself with
those expectations so that at the end of
a period of time you feel good that
you've fulfilled the responsibilities
and third to that this will sound really
really weird that I think every young
person needs an exit strategy I think
that you need to be able to say this
isn't working and feel good about the
fact that you tried with this one
organization this one board but be fine
with resigning if things aren't working
out and and be okay if maybe the
nominating committee doesn't read Amin
8u I mean there's always some nonprofit
board out there that wants your specific
type of leadership and it takes time
sometimes to find that right board I
look back on my first board appointments
and I think that for really quite an
extended period I wasn't actually all
that helpful I was able to help in my
specific skill areas but I think it
takes a great board chair and the right
atmosphere and an understanding of the
vision and mission of the organization
before you really are in a position to
see where you can yourself can
contribute fully
I think of board service like dating you
go out on some dates if you if you're if
you like the organization you continue
to date and you can get married sometime
later but I think the best thing is to
learn by doing and get started and if
you feel you made a mistake on the first
board transition off that but stay in
the social innovation business